are you today sir
I'm good Steve how are you doing good to
see you good to see you again um so it's
been like eight years since you may
attack them yeah and I am curious did
you ever come close to making something
else since attack the block or was it oh
wait you know what I mean talk a little
bit about why it took so long for a
second film well it was a number of
reasons first of all I went straight
into writing ant-man we they go right
after attacked the block so I'd started
on we'd started on that way before
attack the block and we needed to see
that through to completion and that in
fact took us to 2014 and in that period
of time I was attached to I wrote a
screenplay of Snow Crash I was attached
to a project called rust I also was
attached to a project called section six
or really good scripts but they never
quite made it across the finish line and
then in fact 2012 I started thinking
about this movie started writing it in
about 2014 started making it in 20
writing in 2016 making it in 2017 time
flies you know movies take a long time
especially an original movie with it has
a Patrick Stewart and Rebecca Ferguson
but it's driven by unknowns like attack
the block it's not based on a brand or
an IP you know original stuff takes the
time to take off and but I apologize it
was so long I just wanted to give people
plenty of time to think about things
between the movies completely I want to
I thought you did such a great job with
this so I'm Q I just want to say I just
hope that you are making more movies
soon because you have a great you're
really good behind the camera I
appreciate that man I've worked on
something else so I've got a script
that's that I think is in pretty good
shape needs a bit more work and I'm
gonna try and get it done faster that's
what I didn't have before attack the
block I didn't have the next thing ready
so I'm gonna try and I've tried to not
make that mistake again I feel like I'm
in front of the movie's headmaster being
ticked off for being late for my movie
homework no I listen a Cornish come on
look I I think I think it does I think
people don't realize that sometimes
does take time and you want to make
something great you know yeah plus it
was I got to be honest it was I got so
many amazing kind of approaches and
stuff after attack the block that it was
a bit kind of confusing for my career
compass so many different opportunities
it kind of stopped me in my tracks a
little it was like so many doors opening
you don't really know which one to go
through and I didn't want to leap into a
massive movie that I couldn't handle you
know so instead I kind of took refuge in
the process of writing ant-man nestled
under Edgar's hairy wing and and just
observed for a bit but I'm pleased you
know that I've made something that's
from the heart you know it's it's a
movie I've wanted to make since I was a
little kid so and hopefully you know
that's a worthwhile thing to have
invested all that all those many years
in do you still get thank-you cards for
a John Boy from John boyega for changing
his life he owes me a huge amount of
money and he's still paying it off in no
no I know the thing we were incredibly
lucky to have John for that movie and
there's some sort of saying I can never
quite remember which is you don't you
don't launch people's careers you just
open a door for them and we opened a
door for John and he bolted through all
the way to a different universe and I
mean just incredibly proud to have had a
part in in the beginning of his career
you obviously have a great knack for
casting what was it about Patrick
Stewart that you think is gonna make it
for a career well he was in John
Boorman's Excalibur which is one of the
inspirations for this movie and he
hasn't done much since and I thought I'd
give him a helping hand sure you know I
took I take seven years between movies
how long has it been since John thirty
or forty exactly you know no we were
very lucky to have him he's I kind of
think of his role in this movie a bit
like Sean Connery's role in Time Bandits
which is another of my favorite movies
where Time Bandits is led by kind of a
cast of unknowns but then it has this
one star who appears three or four times
and has a real influence over the movie
so Patrick Stewart is our Sean Connery
for this movie what what being
completely serious you really do have a
knack for casts
I think that the actor who plays a young
Merlin is fantastic right if you had
told me that he was been in a comeback
Cumberbatch his younger brother I would
believe you right
also Andy Serkis his son is your main
lead right what was it about these
actors and talk a little bit about the
casting process cuz you really do have a
knack for it well I appreciate that I
can't take the credit really because of
course all directors work with casting
directors so we had a fantastic lady
called Jessica Renan who's the casting
director at the Old Vic Theatre in
London and casts all the Billy Elliot's
for the Billy Elliot musical all over
the world so she just did this big
process of finding thousands of kids and
it's a real meritocracy you know you
bring in a kid whatever their experience
whether they're into drama at school
whether they've done nothing whether
they've done little staged parts whether
they're I've had little parts in movies
like Louie had and you put them in front
of a camera and you give them a scene
you shoot it you take the tape home you
watch it you think could this be in a
movie and with John with Angus with
Louie with Rihanna with Dean with well
you know with all the people I've worked
with there you just sit at home watching
their tape and you think oh this could
be on a big screen so it's a less
scientific job than I always thought it
was casting you just cast who you
believe and I'm lucky enough to have had
really talented people turn up at the
auditions the I'm always curious I love
talking about the editing process
because that's the final rewrite what
did you learn from early friends and
family screenings and if test screenings
that impacted the finished film we
tested this movie a lot and it in fact
from the very first screenings it played
incredibly well with kids aged about
seven all the way up to 214 like sort of
off the charts well and we made it a bit
less frightening because some kids were
being freaked out by Morgana
so we toned it down we adjusted the mix
a bit we had a lot of very scary voices
a lot of heavy stuff in the low end of
the mix we adjusted the mix we trimmed
up the pace a little bit but there were
no massive revelations what was
satisfying was that a kind of wish
fulfillment movie
about this kid finding the sword in the
stone is a sort of wish fulfillment
movie for me as well because I thought
of it when I was a kid and to get to
make it is a wish fulfillment for me and
what was satisfying in the test
screenings was it seemed to be working
as a wish fulfillment movie for kids of
the age I was when I thought of it and
that was really exciting I am curious
what you learned playing someone who
gets the autograph in Notting Hill that
changed your trajectory and now how do
you mean I'm good that could be wrong
but I think you got like you were like
an extra if you will uh Notting Hill or
am I wrong That's not me I was it I I'm
in the background of last Jedi okay yep
IMDB is wrong no I'm flattered that's a
good mistake for IMDB to make sure well
that's completely no I knew you played a
trooper of some kind yes in last Jedi
yeah
well Ryan approached me because he knew
he needed someone out of focus in the
background and he knew it was such an
important role to have a kind of weird
very tall slightly camp rebel soldier in
the background of one of his shots and I
agreed to do it for a large sum of money
and I think I carry that movie I don't
think it would be the success it was
without me I'm agreeing but actually
being Siri
thinks there's one of the things it's my
last question with last Jedi and with
this movie that that's something that I
really love about both is that it says
anyone can be a hero right and that's
something that I think all of us it's
just a great message can you sort of
talk about that aspect of this yeah well
one of the things I thought was
interesting and a lot of mythology and
particularly British mythology whether
it's Harry Potter or the King Arthur
story or Oliver Twist is they're all
about these kids from powerful families
who get abandoned and bought up by a
normal family and then at a certain
point in the story discover this amazing
heritage and I thought there was
something a little weird about that in
terms of the narratives were telling our
kids and the world should be a place
where anybody can achieve anything on
the basis of the choices they make and
who they are and what they do in the
world
so I thought it'd be cool to tell us
about a boy that believes in those myths
the myth of hera of king arthur who also
is obsessed as a child with Harry Potter
and Star Wars and all these films about
bloodline and destiny and then the
journey he goes on actually flips that
entirely and makes him realize that he's
none of those things but yet he can
still achieve the heroic end plus the
key thing about King Arthur is the round
table and if you read the myth it's
never explicitly about Arthur it's about
all the knights and all their different
side quests and Arthur's actually quite
a tragic figure he's not the sort of
unbeatable irrepressible hero of
Mythology he's quite flawed and troubled
and Camelot goes through terrible
suffering so the myth itself is very
meritocratic it's very much about a team
a unity a group of people working
together to achieve a name it's not that
soul solo hero myth that that has been
so common
you